bien nous resterons toujours à cas nous
ne retrouvons comme chaque soir nos
spécialistes maison jean françois téaldi
andré grandissent raoul mille et surtout
coluche l'événement de la journée c'est
le film de dino risi n'ont finalement il
vaut mieux pas parler d'événement je
parlerai du film de la journée
parce que parler l'événement s'est donné
beaucoup trop d'importance à coluche et
étant donné qu'il déteste les
journalistes et bien il faut bien qu'on
lui rende la monnaie d'après la pièce
donc le film aujourd'hui présenté chez
maud et guérin le fou de guerre de dino
risi raoul mille vous en parle à moi je
voudrais simplement vous parler de
l'ambiance à conférence de presse
coluche a été détestable comme toujours
tout le monde le sait il se fait mousser
qui fait sa publicité c'est normal mais
étant donné qu'ils nous aiment pas et
bien nous non plus on n'a pas été très
très agréable avec lui on a un petit peu
aiguillonner je vous pose d'écouter un
extrait la conférence de presse où il
nous un petit peu allumé d'ailleurs on
lui a bien rendu et coûté que les je
voudrais vous poser une question s'il
vous plaît vous et vous êtes tous devant
mouloud mammeri fait vous qui êtes anti
conventionnel divan en pays tout entier
mais vous critiquez un petit peu tout le
monde même les journalistes c'est un
droit que vous avez nous on a aussi le
nôtre vous grattez pas même pour nous
critiquer wind it war si jamais vous
remportiez quelque chose à ce festival
oui vous entrevoyez dans le système ça
serait antico en char est chiant un bas
c'est chiant pour bourassa serait
terrible mais pour vous c'est chiant non
arrêts vous trouvez que je cherchais
quelque chose qui pourrait me merdé
c'est ça bah dites moi passer votre vie
à essayer d'emmerder le monde quoi
auprès du tout que vous croyez
vieux non non on avait si j'ai appris je
mettrais par dessus le tad on dit que
j'ai déjà eu et qu'est-ce que tu joues
au foot
moi je les mets dans les chiottes voilà
donc pour cet échange de mots
aigres-doux qu'il ait eu entre coluche
et la presse et ma personne puisque je
l'avais pas agresser mais je vais poser
des questions il me semblait j'avais
droit de poser
raoul mille alors ce film che mardi
guerre et bien c'est un film où on
retrouve dino risi le dino risi de
parfum de dames de parfum de femme dino
risi des grandes années on retrouve chez
lui l'ironie la cruauté la bouffonnerie
dans cette histoire qui se passe en
libye ou aux coluche interprète à
capitaine et ce qui est plus grave ce
chirurgien complètement fou et mettons
tendre aussi quelquefois parce que ce
fou et bien tout simplement on comprend
que c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas aimé
et que peut-être le manque d'amour peut
conduire tout simplement à la folie et
puis la réfection de dino risi c'est que
la folie de coluche dans le film c'est
aussi la folie ambiante
c'est tout simplement la folie de la
guerre qui est fou pendant la guerre
tout le monde est fou est d'ailleurs
l'un des personnages du film dan hardy
il dit bien vous savez plus ou moins
fous pendant la guerre ça n'a pas
tellement d'importance
donc je vois que 10 rosie a fait un beau
film un film qui aurait pu être un très
grand film city il n'y avait justement
on revient à coluche l'interprétation de
coluche moi j'ai pensé pendant tout le
film à vittorio gassman et j'aurais
préféré vittorio gassman à coluche et
d'être pris de dire ça quand on est
français mais coluche manque des mesures
visage du chien présenté dans le cadre
de perspectives du cinéma français c'est
le premier film de jacek gasiorowski en
réalisateur polonais mme gas est quasi
europe ce qui selon vous dit peut être
rien et pourtant il était le premier
assistant du film danton d'andrzej page
la mazda qui d'ailleurs le conseiller
artistique de ce film un film qui n'a pu
voir le jour que grâce à une association
du niçois jp c'est en cours qui en
produit ce film
jean pierre cassel qu'est ce qui vous a
donné l'idée de produire ses premiers
rôles eh bien on avait regroupé avoir eu
nombre des moulins à soi ou de la côte
d'azur en général dans une société de
production et au moment où nous
cherchons un premier film à produire
nous avons rencontré ya chuck qui est
cédée lui-même embarqué dans cette
aventure le mot aventure nous a séduit
c'était déjà celui qui présidait à
l'essence de la société si vous avez eu
l'idée de tourner un film sur la drogue
sous cet angle ce qui est enfin je veux
dire ce qui m'intéressait pas et sort de
la danse et plus tolérante internet ici
je pense c'est l'essentiel ans est fier
et qui est beaucoup plus important que
il fait enfin le terroriste la situation
des dangers qui crée un rapport spécial
entre le père et fils visage du chien il
ya sec des mesures au speed